it's a school trip dad I'll be fine like
I'm going in more dangerous the green
inferno is the third film in what I
would call my travel trilogy with cabin
fever and hostel the kids in green
inferno are these really smart new york
city students there click to vist their
on social media their social justice
warriors they're going to change the
world with their phones and they go into
the Amazon to save the last uncontacted
tribe they're going to protect them it's
time to make a difference the moment in
the movie where these kids are happiest
isn't where they do a protest and shut
down the construction it's when they're
trending on Twitter that's the end game
for these kids and I think it's all bs
they crashed in the jungle and it tribes
people they're like oh they are the ones
that are ripping up our land they're
invaders and we're going to treat them
as such right yeah
shooting in the Amazon was one of the
craziest experience of my life we're
filming in a village that had never seen
cameras before it's dangerous as hell
when you see lorenza izzo in the movie
screaming and clinging to a rock she
really almost drowned even when we
filmed the plane crash we put the cast
in a drum and spun them 720 degrees I
wanted a little to know CG in the movie
I want it to all look and feel real and
that's what makes the movie special I
feel that Hollywood movies have gotten
so safe and so stale and they're all in
a house in a room but I miss those films
of the 70s
I missed the filmmaking of Verner Herzog
the way did Fitz Corrado Aguirre the
wrath of God I miss Apocalypse Now when
you go oh my god the people that made
these movies they went in the jungle and
they lost their mind why are they doing
this the film came about from what I saw
in this trend of this lazy form of
activism this slacktivism everyone's
like if you don't tweet free Riot
what's wrong with you don't you care
about these girls oh you must be against
freedom sweet people are getting so
self-righteous and so angry over this
thing that they knew nothing about 24
hours earlier I wanted to make a movie
about these types of kids these kids
that aren't really interested in the
cause they want the short cut I am so
sick of all of them so I'm taking these
people and I'm baking them and I'm
chopping them up and eating them and I'm
laughing at them